welcome to las vegas' side in spanish
your connection to the digital world of
entertainment here in las vegas
greets you native and has kept today let's start
with news of shows
in our city and that is that the
rock band metallica and the piano media novel
are coming  to feel and I'm talking
about two different shows one weekend
in the same city it was announced that both
will perform at station auditions
this February
metallica will perform first on
Friday the 25th while the video will do so
the following night on the 26th tickets for
both  shows go on sale this friday
let's talk now about an iconic show that
has just opened in the script it is the
holographic tour of the singer
whitney houston kicking off her
North American residency in xerez this show
consists of a hologram of the late
singer together with
original recordings of their songs dancers and
a live band and i've been
writing it on their screens and if you
ever have that  great to see award-winning
singer adam lambert live still have
time to enjoy his
unlimited residency here in las vegas tickets are still
available for his shows
at the venice resort which culminate
this october 30th
well while for the new
2022 series of  Comedy geniuses
are on sale now This series starting
in January will feature over 40
performances by iconic comedians
like George Lopez, Rey Romano, David Spade
and more. You can find your tickets at
Ticketmaster.com.
Well, now let's talk about Halloween in Las
Vegas.  and it is that this is a city of
ours rather that has
entertainment options that are practically
endless but I will present some of
these that stood out for me starting
with a unique era of celebrating these
festivities of the nights of the
witch's night rather to the  open air it
's a boulder
city costume party by rail scouts
you can go dressed up when  Any
day from today until this Sunday and
enjoy this outdoor activity
the cost is 95 dollars per
couple or 165 for 4 people
and from the desert we go to the
male live shark aquarium and which will be
transformed into something spooky this
weekend  On weekdays, in addition to this, it will extend
its hours of attention and you will add
surprises for its visitors. Children
under 12 years of age who have dressed
up rather paid an entrance fee of 5
dollars. You can make your reservation on the
website of Mandalay Bay Dotcom
and from the aquarium to the zoo.  the
lion habitat ranch is holding its
annual buades you celebration this October
daily from 11 in the morning until
three in the afternoon culminating this Sunday
, October 31 the cost of admission is
20 dollars and children under 14 years old
are free
good  I know that you arrived saying to las
vegas' side in Spanish do not forget to
visit our page and indignant
dotcom to see these activities and
much more I salute you  to a bad
sound attack see you next week
[Music]